hey what's going on guys it's rob and
welcome to my tutorial for the
[Music]
[Applause]
triple transforming ninja star
so i'm back and teaching you guys a
totally new design i called up jeremy
schaefer and i asked for his help to
create a three-pointed transforming
ninja star so he teamed up once again to
create this epic model that transforms
from this to this and we both made our
own tutorials for it i was amazed at how
far and accurate it flew in the frisbee
mode i even got those two in a bag by
accident without even trying not only
that it flies really fast and i'll show
you how at the end
it can not only fly straight while
transform but curves around in a circle
slightly if you throw it in a certain
way but usually doesn't come all the way
back
and it flies like this
be sure to check out jeremy's tutorial
too which i'll put a card for in the
upper right hand of the video
once you get the hang of making the
three identical pieces and locking them
together you'll be in for hours of fun
transforming it and throwing it it may
be a bit tricky in some parts for
beginners since there's some geometry
involved so i recommend you check out
some of my other videos which i'll put
some cards for above and link in the
description below i'm going to be using
three letter size printer sheets like
these since it's a bit thinner and
easier to fold and get something like
this however if you want to use colored
paper to get a star like this that's
fine too once you have the paper let's
get right into it set the paper so that
the longer edges are horizontal and then
take the top of the paper and align it
with the bottom edge
make a nice sharp crease along the top
and then you can run your fingernail
against it with the open edges facing
down we can take the upper right corner
and airplane fold it down to the bottom
so that the right edge aligns with the
very bottom edge again make a nice sharp
crease now we can open up the triangle
and now fold it backwards on that same
fold which we just made crease it once
again open up the triangle and once
again fold it to the front and flatten
it out take the very top edge now and
fold it down to the bottom rounding the
paper as necessary if it may be a little
bit thick line up the two edges and
crease sharply along the top of the
paper now we're going to rotate the
paper until it is upside down making
sure that the triangle portion we folded
is facing us but is on the left now we
can now take just this top layer of the
paper and fold the top edge down to the
bottom line up the two edges and press
down creasing throughout as always make
sure that the crease is nice and sharp
turn the paper upside down so the fold
we made is on the back with the triangle
facing right and fold the entire top
edge and all the layers down to the
bottom just sharpen the top edges of the
paper here by creasing sharply with our
fingernail also crease on the right here
although the paper might be thicker we
can now open the entire sheet of paper
once we've completed the initial
precreases your paper should look like
this and we can now move on to the next
step you'll notice when you look at the
paper that there's actually a y in it
and the bottom part of the y is in the
middle and it's a valley folder our next
step is turning the paper into this so
that we can collapse everything like so
let's now flip the paper over and make
the two last precreases take the upper
right corner and fold the top edge to
the second vertical crease from the left
so fold it down and align it with that
second vertical line and crease sharply
you may need to round the paper a little
bit
once you've made a sharp crease unfold
and then we could do the same on the
left side so now fold the left top edge
and align it with the second vertical
crease from the right creasing sharply
and unfolding we could flip the paper
over once again you should now see a
diamond on the top side towards the
center that originates from the bottom
of the y to the second horizontal line
from the top of the paper we can now
turn the paper clockwise as we had it
before to make the collapsing of the
paper easier we're now going to fan the
paper to make the folds in the paper the
way we need them most of you probably
know how to make a fan but just remember
that the better you made the creases
earlier will make the step a whole lot
easier so be sure you creased well first
we could take the top edge and fold it
down on the first crease
then we could fold backwards or away
from us and then we could fold towards
us creasing the paper as we go
once again fold the top backwards or
away from us then just repeat throughout
the paper away from us and then towards
us until we have completely fanned out
the paper once you're done it should
look like this from the side at this
point your paper should look like this
with the side view showing four v's i'm
going to set it down on the table and
flatten it gently just make sure the y
is on the right side i'm then going to
fold the right edge inwards at the first
crease just like this and crease it all
the way throughout the paper i'm now
going to pick up the paper and take the
top edge and the right edge and pinch
the corner together here like this at
the diagonal at the same time if you
look at the bottom you'll notice that we
have two edges which are attached to
that corner right here
i'm going to push upwards on the
diagonal crease which is in the middle
of those edges and at the same time
squeeze those two edges together when
you do that you'll see it might get a
little crinkled which is okay i'm now
going to do the same on the other corner
here
pinch the corner on the diagonal and
squeeze the two bottom edges together
now i'm going to tug a bit on those
corners and pull them apart gently when
you do that it should pop up this
horizontal crease here so it becomes a
mountain fold but if it doesn't pop up
you can also push upwards on it from the
bottom as i am doing here just like this
the very top outside edge here should
also be touching that popped up crease
as you could see here
it should look like this now with a sort
of box on the bottom as you could see
i'm now going to hold both corners with
my thumbs and middle fingers and take
both pointer fingers and push with both
fingers on the horizontal fold in the
middle of the diamond you see here then
i'm going to bring both pointers towards
the corners that i'm holding when you do
that you'll see that there are two new
edges here on both sides near the
corners which i'm now going to once
again squeeze together when you do that
you'll now have a new box that's even
narrower we can now set it down on the
table if you haven't done so already if
we now push inwards on the two vertical
edges sticking up you'll notice that
this top edge here will bend inwards
slightly
i'm now going to pull that edge inwards
more and then push down all the way on
that top edge
when we do that all three edges will
fold inwards towards the center you'll
notice that it will kind of create these
little rabbit ears here
take these rabbit ear flaps and fold
them upwards creating new creases push
them down all the way up until they are
completely flat once we finish doing
that we can flatten out the entire paper
so it's completely collapsed and looks
just like this
all that's left to do now is to fold it
in half
take the top edge and fold it down you
might need to use your fingernail to
smooth out the center since the edges in
the middle may be close together or
touching but don't worry too much about
it once you've completely folded it in
half flatten it as best you can and we
can move on now that we've finished
collapsing the paper we need to lock the
opposite end which doesn't have the
flaps to do that we can open it to the
center and airplane fold both top
corners into the center making nice
sharp creases as we do so then we can
unfold the right side and if you open
the edges you'll notice there's actually
two separate layers we're going to take
the back layer here and tuck or reverse
fold that back edge into the center like
this and press down we can then pull
back on the front layer and fold that
front corner over and into that edge
that was tucked in afterwards press it
closed now all we need to do is to
unfold the left side and close the
entire paper back together you'll see we
now have a free corner here and if you
take your fingernail you'll notice
there's a little pocket here that you
can open round off the left corner and
tuck it into that pocket which is now on
the right side to lock the ends together
we now need to work on the flaps on the
end of the piece which both interlock
and slide in a track on the other pieces
to do that we need to create a 60 degree
fold no worries no measurements are
necessary however we need to be as neat
as possible and make sure you're lining
up the edges properly to ensure that the
ninja star locks together correctly we
can take the piece we just created and
hold the flaps on the right like this
with both ends slanted down as i'm
positioning it here we can take the top
flap and fold it in half from top to
bottom but only from right about here
this creates a horizontal crease which
divides the flap in half
and now i'm just going to draw on it so
that you can see the crease a little bit
easier
we are now going to fold the top flap
tip in at this corner and if you look
you should notice it already has a
vertical crease already in the paper
here fold it inwards like this and
notice the edge lines up with the back
corner also now set it down on the table
and while holding the tip so it doesn't
shift we need to take the right edge of
that triangle and line up the bottom
corner with the horizontal line while
the top edge lines up with the corner
here on top so i'm going to hold the
point with my left pointer and lift up
the right edge rounding it a bit to make
it easier i'm trying to get the bottom
corner on the horizontal line and the
right edge towards the top corner as you
can see i did it incorrectly here so i
need to lift that edge so it goes all
the way from the horizontal line to the
very top once we've done that make a
nice sharp crease in the paper as you
can see now the corner goes from the
horizontal line and the edge lines up
with the top corner now we can unfold it
and then unfold it once more we now have
a small excess triangle that is sticking
out from behind the tip that we folded
in we need to fold it upwards along the
bottom of the triangle and crease it
then lift up the first layer of the top
flap to open it up so we could tuck it
inside you should notice we made a new
crease in the paper right here which is
60 degrees so let me once again mark it
so you can see it easier you can see
that we have created a pretty accurate
equilateral triangle here on the front
flap at this point we're going to fold
it once again on the same crease i've
drawn but inwards towards the center or
inside of the flaps just like this now
we can just flatten the paper out and
finish making our first piece to
complete the piece all we need to do is
to take the back flap and fold it along
the edge that we now have from the front
flap so lift up the back corner along
the edge all the way and give it a nice
sharp crease
you may notice but that basically
replicates that 60 degree fold that we
created on the front triangular flap
then we can open the center of the flaps
and tuck the back flap in towards the
center on the new crease that we just
created flip it over and just fold that
excess corner on top down like this the
piece is now complete but let's just
reinforce those outside folds here by
sharpening them with our fingernail and
there you go we have finished one piece
and you need to make two more in the
exact same way and then we can interlock
them to interlock the pieces make sure
you're holding it so that the locked
ends are slanted downwards to the left
and the open ends or flaps are slanted
up to the right so pick up two pieces
and hold them the same way now i'm going
to take the bottom red one and rotate it
counter clockwise or to the left until
the top of the red flap edges are even
with the top of the blue one i'm then
going to place the bottom of the blue
piece in between the flaps of the red
one you'll notice there are actually
three separate tracks on top an outside
a middle and a second outside one unfold
the front red triangle open the very
outside track of the blue piece and tuck
the red triangle inside push it all the
way in until it's flat with the top of
the blue piece now we can take the back
red triangular flap and unfold it all
the way and wrap that flap around on top
of the front red flap like this
now open up the outside pocket on the
red piece
tuck it into that little pocket
and press down firmly and there you go
that's how you interlock the pieces and
once you're done you can see it is
sliding quite nicely here now we can
interlock the last piece for the last
one if you get confused as to how it
needs to be positioned hold it over the
other pieces you'll see the red one is
positioned this way the blue one is
positioned a bit clockwise like this
meaning the last yellow one needs to be
positioned like this
so let's lock the blue and yellow ones
next just like before hold one piece in
each hand slide the bottom of the yellow
piece with the pockets upwards in
between the blue pieces flaps now you
get it take the front blue triangle flap
and tuck it into the very outside track
facing you until the edge is flush or
even with the top of the yellow piece
once again take the back blue flap and
wrap it around and open the outside blue
pocket and fold the excess into it and
press down to do the last lock take the
bottom closed edge of the red piece and
slide it between the yellow flaps
now you know what to do
take the front yellow triangle flap put
it into the outside track of the red
piece
then take the back yellow flap wrap it
around to the front and tuck the excess
into the outside pocket of the yellow
piece i wouldn't put it in the center
because i find it pops out easier but
you're free to experiment with it just
press and flatten it out and you've
completed the triple transforming ninja
star to transform it all you need to do
is to break and work it in a bit but if
you push on the pieces inward either at
the same time or consecutively it will
transform into this awesome
three-pointed star opening is basically
the reverse but i found if you wiggle it
a little bit it helps and once you're
done there's your transforming ninja
star to throw it in the frisbee
configuration hold it like this so that
this is slanted up to the right and put
your finger on top here and hold it
between the other three fingers like
this and you're going to rotate and
flick your wrist like a frisbee
i found that the lighter white paper
flies in a circle a little bit better
than the colored paper which is heavier
so you might want to try that one
instead
hey guys thanks for watching my tutorial
for the triple transforming ninja star i
hope you guys were able to make it and
that you enjoyed it as much as i did i'd
also like to thank jeremy for working
together with me on it i have some more
video plans coming up for the future so
if you haven't already click the
subscribe thumbs up button and the
notification bell so you stay notified i
know i've been mia for quite a while but
with things looking up i'm definitely
gonna be coming back with some new
videos soon so be sure to stay notified
and i'll see you guys soon